disruption and disruptive innovation
disruptive technology great disruptive
thinkers disruptions and disruptors
disrupting disrupting disruptive I'm we
love the word disrupt don't we disrupt
the word on your boss is insufferable
LinkedIn profile next to the picture of
him and his Tesla disrupt is a tech
buzzword for making things better and as
tech companies undermine major
industries and take over public services
we have to ask are they making things
better are they saving us from an
economy and a government that don't work
for most people or is their success a
sign that the worst is yet to come it
might be time to disrupt the disrupting
[Music]
[Applause]
every year tech becomes more and more
part of our lives from what we buy to
where we stay on vacation to which
stranger with too much cologne on we
allow to drive us home at night his
name's Chuck and I gave him five stars
cuz he let me crack the window to
fumigate the steady encroachment of tech
reminds me of what it must have been
like when we first discovered fire at
first it made our life a lot easier
warming up your cave and cooking your
food but then one day you wake up and
your whole family is covered in it and
you're like this is a little
overwhelming but tech is cool and that's
a plus when you want to distract news
anchors from the potential downsides of
saved 7-eleven delivering you food by
drone the world's largest convenience
store chain revealed yesterday that it
has delivered items to 77 customers in
Reno Nevada you know what I can order a
Slurpee it's never love and they're my
parents houses from my marriage how's
that work too much government regulate I
used to walk to the 7-eleven you know
that now I can get it yeah Wow and
that's how you make the news all about
yourself next up we'll mention
California's drought and Myka will tell
a story about beating her brother in a
squirt gun fight in 1974 and tech
companies don't just sell us on
convenience and cool but also the idea
that there's nothing wrong with
disrupting the market because innovation
is progress like harmony the talking sex
robot progress and innovation always
leads to better results right a new
report out now so
as Airbnb is driving up rental prices
and housing availability in New York
City Airbnb is playing a role in
exacerbating the housing crisis that's
already going on here in Los Angeles
nearly three quarters of Airbnb listings
between 2010 and 2014 were essentially
illegal hotels ride-sharing vehicles
averaging more than 170 thousand trips
in the city each weekday several drivers
have band together in a class-action
lawsuit against the company claiming
uber miss classifies them as independent
contractors and owes them money for
expenses like gas and vehicle
maintenance uber claimed there third
party background checks were sufficient
but nearly a hundred drivers were found
to have failed the checks with drivers
who committed fraud assault duis and
even possessed fake IDs okay but what
about the free gum a little waters but
the bigger impact of tech companies
isn't just that they're disrupting
retail taxi and hotel industry's public
transportation labor rights or the
housing market it's that they're
undermining them take New York City the
one place that arguably didn't need
ride-hailing apps with the amount of
yellow cabs car services and a subway
system where you can watch men dislocate
their shoulders for like a buck in just
the last four years the number of for
hire vehicles operating in New York City
more than doubled and almost two-thirds
of them are now uber cars as a rider
trying to get uptown quickly that sucks
unless your favorite pastime is watching
pedestrians beat you whoa look at that
one go she's got a cane but imagine
being a driver like Doug's shifter
shifter had been a limo driver since the
80s and in early February he shot and
killed himself outside City Hall in
Manhattan in what seemed to be an act of
exasperation at the industry he built a
career in in a Facebook post he said he
could no longer make ends meet even when
working a hundred hours a week on top of
that he felt let down by New York City's
politicians for failing to regulate and
corporate execs for not caring and his
sentiments are echoed by taxi cab
drivers to SFO a day has been driving
for 27 years and he says thanks to burr
he now has nothing to show for it I
don't have my life I work 12 hours a day
I pretty much worked just to survive
okay but uber says they give drivers
flexibility take the day off
or pay rent disrupt alright let's ask
tech listen to former uber CEO Travis
kalanick justify his work we look at all
of the cities and we know that the
transportation systems there are just
not they're not serving everybody's
needs I mean even here in New York with
a great mass transit system there's
still two and a half million cars going
over those bridges every day we just
believe we can help the city do better
by building another bridge and donating
to the MTA I'm sorry I'm just playing
we're adding more cars and making tons
of dough still Callen ik although an
unmitigated douchebag is unfortunately
not wrong because many mass transit
systems including the New York subway
are sorely neglected it's so bad that
Pizza rat was the best thing to happen
to the New York subway system in decades
I'm surprised the MTA didn't just make
it its mascot but fixing what the
government hasn't is something big tech
constantly claims it does politicians
have failed you the economy has failed
you and rather than change it Texas
they're here to help I was pretty much
just struggling to make ends meet in and
out of work they couldn't pay my
mortgage I was having a lot of
difficulty when I finally came to
borough was probably the best thing
that's happened air B&B can give us an
extra income to help us survive a little
bit better in the past second wages and
pretty much stayed the same while costs
have gone up drive with uber and put a
dollar sign in front of your odometer
like this guy technically I'm a cook
yeah technically he's a cook but since
there's no stability in the restaurant
industry he's got to drive drunk 23 year
olds around and hope they don't puke in
his car now sure renting your place on
Airbnb or driving for ride hail
companies might be solid temporary fixes
but when they go unregulated these
precarious jobs don't become the
disruption in the market they make
precarious jobs the rule of the market
which is how you get a worsening of the
housing crisis and the destruction of
taxis and the reason you can't stay in
your childhood bedroom when you go home
for Thanksgiving because it's now a
suburban
Mace's really mom at a time when we have
more income inequality since before the
Great Depression the services these apps
provide are overwhelmingly being used by
people who are wealthier making you
wonder if these companies are helping to
close the income gap or prying it wide
open tech isn't here to help you survive
the vampire bite of capitalism it's here
to find a new space on your neck and of
course since big tech is so gallantly
stepping into profit off of the
government and our economy's failures it
only makes sense that one company is
trying to tackle the biggest failure of
them all Amazon is at it again and this
could be a game-changer for healthcare
Amazon Berkshire Hathaway and JPMorgan
Chase are forming an independent
healthcare company for its employees
great idea because there's no reason to
think that the employees you overworked
and underpaid be under cared for by your
health care by the way you're not a
health care company how much you want to
bet Amazon's coverage is just to cover
people in bubble wrap and you can pop
some of those bubbles to distract you
from the pain disrupt health care but
just because these companies want to own
more and more of our lives doesn't mean
they should be able to which brings us
to the R word the word that makes every
Fox News host shudder regulation listen
to how this conservative pundit argues
against regulating the unfettered use of
drones you're asking the government to
get involved and to be the one to
regulate what's going on about
technology I agree with you I don't want
them flying on my head but I'm gonna get
a helmet I have little kids they love
the drone there's nothing you can do
about it yeah get a helmet that's what
being an American is all about having
needless workarounds for easily
regulatable tragedies I got my drone
helmet my acid rain helmet my stray
bullet helmet my rape helmet my oil fill
in the drinking water helmet and my
night on the town helmet so but despite
the legions of lobbyists hired by tech
companies to fight laws restricting them
cities and states have started to
regulate cities like London Seattle
Baltimore Detroit and Vancouver have
been placing taxes and restrictions on
short-term rental services like Airbnb
Berlin was able to bring back a towel
and housing units to the market and
ride-hailing services have been limited
text and subjected to more oversight in
states like Michigan Massachusetts and
Texas which will help raise driver wages
reduce traffic and bring more money to
those states because not all disruption
is a bad thing
uber and lyft probably prevent a lot of
drunk driving and one time I stayed in a
treehouse in Nashville it was awesome
but maybe it's time to rethink how Tech
isn't fixing our real problems instead
it's a band-aid falling off the gaping
wound left by the thing we should
disrupt most of all that vampire called
capitalism thanks for watching news
broke again I'm Francesca fiorentina
follow me on twitter at Franny Pheo and
please share this video with your
network to give them a more thorough
picture of the effects of the apps that
they might be using every day and also
will you please go to our review page
and give us a five star review on
Facebook watch because the trolls they
come out this is my fact helmet and
you're wearing your shirt that says
feminist and I feel threatened one-star
so thank you for giving us a review and
we'll see you next week